[Musik]
schon immer sucht der mensch der bezug
zum göttlichen im eigenen herzen der
natur oder religion die spirituelle weg
sind vielseitig im zweiten teil ging auf
spurensuche ganz spezielle frau nach der
mutter gottes maria
sie soll dem oberhalb steinsalz einer
jahrhundert erschienen sie die erschien
ich verfolge kam und wie hat sie das
geprägt
[Musik]
wird sie miteinander und herz bekommen
das ist dorf stirbt fotokasten im
bündnerland das romanische gegen tauber
wo wirklich berge menschen prägt hat da
eine ganz nebenbei viele wohnt ein
niveau zu einer ganz speziellen ort
darüber dürfe verbindung aufbaut hat er
ist gehört der vorteil das ist der
höchsten maria wallfahrtsort in ganz
europa trifft dort die pfarrer paul
schleer und ursprünglich sehen
er kümmert sich erschienen nummer ums
geistige wohl vorsichtig meint was
machen sie da sind schon richtig durch
für was ich das anders
das gab mir den bericht so zum kaffee
und es bildete sich eine verdächtige
wieder mit einem sieg wieder oder noch
in mir ich hab mich berufen und erzählt
koch klärt und den hahn ist tot der
fachschule macht die sozialen und nach
der spezialisierte sparte citi ok taste
maria hält sich einfach zu bett gehen
sich aber schön wenn meine release
erfahrung und kommen mit ihm umgang ich
das ganz wichtige die richtige zeit die
sie im fokus hat der paul schneider
alles über den marienwallfahrtsort titel
sammelt sie in ganzer stolz ich das bild
da das geschätzte darstellung von deren
marienerscheinungen sieht ja dass ich
geh endlich die darstellung ausgeht
der gott der sich 580 detail erschienen
hier der burg die attacken der mamas und
hätte seidler im tal kurs tour und sich
bekehren und dann hat das natürlich
nicht so einschlug
denn er hätte folglich angeordnet dass
man prozessionen macht und so hat sich
der wald so denn entwickelt aber wenn
ich so das bild alle gesund bin mir aber
recht steigen überall so erhob nica
zeigefinger und serie demütige haltung
ja dank dass das defizit vor der
reformation ist und in ukraine genau der
hinweis der angestellten lehrern und
kultur der marienerscheinung auf knapp
2500 meter über meer salz volk wieder in
katholische drei vereine das könnt ihr
schon fast noch ein konzept und
nacheinander duft reformation was auch
im 16 jahrhundert ausbreitet hat jetzt
schon ein wunder was man von der maria
hat noch spürt mehr als 400 jahre später
ich zeige ihnen grabner wo man doch
unterwegs sind und spirituelle werk sind
da ein teil wird oberhalb von ihnen das
lied idec meint so sees da im tal
oberhaupt steigt das grenzt ohne aktive
carsten und wir sind dann unterwegs sein
wenn in bivio besucher zum september
pass
[Musik]
jetzt katar überrascht wie groß die
rally stark spürt ihr maria
freundlichkeit die erzielung von ctl
geprägt da alles nicht immer recht
strenge geschichte mit bei maria und dem
hinter burg da jetzt hat andere schön
die darstellung sondern fix motor tafel
wo die staffel schönhofer wunder bewirkt
die man ja darüber
[Musik]
sotos tisch
aber wo mir einiges übers tal wundert
sie teilt ralf erzähler ist der lehrer
und exil bündner lienert kann
dreijährigen tiefe kastl aufwachsen und
schon mal die strecke da ein paar das in
der sich aber regelmäßige worden wir
sind in großer regelmäßigkeit schon als
kind später bin ich dennoch nicht leer
ich bin so laut wie nie mit der schüler
rufen und annett ist erwartet und am s
klasse und wenn man eine sehr jung sie
sind sie in algier gern darüber und
übernachtet haben als alle haben ist
natürlich salaten ist und die paletten
immer wieder so ein kontrollgang gemacht
um mitternacht damit man die nötig die
stanze haltet zum weiblichen geschlecht
ich bin aber darauf vertrauen dass kühl
kann es schon berichtet trutzburg ich
unter sohnes so einen wallfahrtsort am
friedberger man muss in die wüste ist
auch das bollwerk gegenüber dem vortag 7
16 jahrhundert dort stand dann nämlich
noch brutal ist samt sich da um mich
natürlich über der belgischen pass sie
und wahrscheinlich hätte man doch mit
der kirche wähler
der vormarsch vom protestantismus vater
dh die erschien vor der maria die hand
also der speck gegenreformation ich auch
wieder so wird wie jetzt netto aber
klarer muss zu einer kirche zu einer
wallfahrt muss man gut geschichte
pflicht aber letzlich erfinder und wenn
ich dann den ort bin und natürlich galt
wieder alexander nutzer sehen und er hat
einige gedichte geschrieben über über
den ort also bei alexander mozer ist ja
dort sozusagen der hürther vollzieht als
sie im kapuziner paar
richtig und methoden pilgerinnen und
pilger entfernen aber es ist nicht immer
so lustig sie als immens natürlich den
rekener zeitung stürmt und regnet immer
kunde und der dreh zum beispiel der
ganzes gedicht geschrieben das gebet
einer pilgerin ums heiligtum zuteil die
stürme jagen im alten dach die balken
ächzen klagen die wiese pfeift hörst du
das glöcklein rufen durchnässte pilger
steigen über stufen aber der nordsee 14
uhr ist natürlich ein architekt sie eine
super party und jäger und mitarbeiter
der oper tosca oder das ist sie ist
jagdrevier sie also über ihn zählt
natürlich einige geschichte als pfarrer
us küste über die der heilige franziskus
und der heilige franziskus hätte gefreut
kann vielleicht ein paar alexander lotz
weil der heilige franziskus in keinem
tier bislang tore
[Musik]
ungewöhnlich dass der wallfahrtsort
auerberg heute nicht und die deren
aufgaben elementen auf der party und
chemischer vater segne uns sehr unsere
familien segel die kranken die kinder
und jugendlichen segel diese gaben die
wir von deiner großen gilde empfangen
werden durch christus unseren herrn
ein guter
sie sind ja voll im element brauchen
wirklich 7 ist ja richtig ist auch dass
ich mit der jugendband linke haben wäre
einfach schön aber jetzt hat es die drei
meter hoch sind jetzt meter hoch oder an
oder für opel sehr schmal so bei
irgendwas wirklich überrascht dass es
schon mal große ipad das zeigt aber die
relative risiko nicht gesichtet die
jetzt so nicht doch immerhin heimlicher
doch und europa von diepoldsau die
stände am 2
und lang führt jedoch was ist schöner
für sie das allerschönste für mich ich
begann mit der lüge und hat auch
auftanken
aber ich genieße das deine erinnerungen
nicht ganz allein
ich habe viele jahre dafür wird er dort
auch wieder viel passieren und das
genieße ich weiß dass ich für mich schön
ja aber auch nur durch das man können
für die hypo sie für sie in den haag mit
ihm schwarzer sich eine gut bewertet und
biete und ich glaube zu tragen da sah
ich dass ich ihn zu ihrer kollegen ganz
klar spiritualität wo man da über die
berge spürt verstärkt auf wir krieg vor
dem gotteshaus ist denn vielleicht gar
nicht mehr so wichtig willi göttlich
instanz nicht beendet
[Musik]
größe zeigen wir machen ja oder nein
der belgier gewicht gewinne bei den
frauen und gewinne deutlich die flucht
eines leiters der jungfrau vom heiligen
geist empfangen hast
das biete prozent
wie du bist
[Musik]
nur wenige kilometer weg aber die wunder
im die brille vom ist teilbetrags
elschot bekannte groß sie vor über 1200
jahre bevor sie grundstück storie kenn
ludmilla seifert warf als er sich eine
für den ältesten sohn uhr besteht wie
sie bauten ich das bild maria wichtige
rolle allerdings ganz andere als in teil
wenn da die schranke war nach der
leerung vom 05
ich kenne wird er vorne machen wir da
stelle ich entdeckte bürger ins taxi mit
einer maria voll mich keiten dass ich
jetzt aber die höfische darstellen oder
mit krone oder mitgebracht
maria im kontext mit ganzen und marias
analyse des königs bild was ich einfach
eine rolle spielt sich dargestellt mit
einem bus mit der krone als
himmelskönigin
das heißt aber jede zieht macht sich
auch iris bild von maria zum beispiel
oder jetzt
so schön sehr schön gewandete chronisch
als er das sind teil der ausstellung
problem sind die erde kreist köpfe der
wilde sind es die zeit um 1400 mache ich
mir bei riesige stoffmuster nach dem
areal nach sieben meter hoch oder so
oder so und sprachen immer groß
dargestellt um die sieben meter hoch
häufig ist es an der kirche und die
größe und die monumentalität aber grund
würden sie schreien nach als lotto
pilger heilige wenn man da aber liegt
den hessen eigentlich von mir tod
bewahrt also vor der ewigen verdammnis
sie dann sehen wo der gallushalle und
was ich denn dort ausstellen mit denen
ganze 80 sogenannte feiertags christus
das ist eine seltene darstellung
abließen gewählt ab und zu erforschen
und das ist dass man bild aus der
mystische volksfrömmigkeit und den wald
die wartezeit wenn man eine person
tecnet durch die brucher weil wenn man
sie braucht denn dort man richtungs
immer wieder familien leid zufügen und
darum mich richtung mit infizierten
körper der eigenen mitglieder gestellt
hat das bilderbuch oder verglüht
entlastet und das verstorbene sich
essmann bild die einfachen leute
eigentlich
[Musik]
vom ist eilbeschluss gott zudem alte
bilder und super weg richtig sagte
mappus
mit perleffekt geht's da bildstöckle
vielen und kapelle sicher auch zum
möglichst viel himmlische schutz über
vor für der lange weg im süden oder im
norden
[Musik]
und ein mensch begegnet mir doch immer
wieder alexander lotz an das legendäre
kapuzinerpater dass sich sogar als
priester aber nicht aufgegangen und man
erzählt sich ein vergifteter
fußballvereins sie und wer es in die
mannschaft weg verloren haben vorstellen
der viele regen im tal zeigen mit
religion lang der alltag von der
menschen prägt hat braun wir präsent der
katholische glaube durch das hypnotische
es oder gibt es vielleicht neuzugang zum
alten glaube mit den gedanken im kopf um
das dorf hat dass er die renommierte
wakkerpreis vom spitzer heimatschutz
überhaupt mit der leidigen ortsbild
sondern mehrere kulturelle institution
wo origin heißt der initiant vom projekt
drittel der giovanni netzer sektoren
probesitzen schauspielerinnen und
schauspieler
was sind sie jetzt dort an proben proben
stück für die julia dass wir jetzt den
zehnthof wird es ist ein ball und in den
ball regietheater revolution friedlich
im publikum versteckt sind
da hätte da führerin vorrevolutionären
truppe die ihre figuren aus die welt die
uns was sie massive für das thema und
die andere seite zu versehen
brachial und böse artus ich brauche
spiele bei aller welt unterwegs und der
klasse der sakrale räume eröffnen hat
mit religion zu glauben also dass ich
bin kein theologe und haben mit denen
ganze geschichte gewachsen
der mini theatrale heimat ist grade rom
also das was aus dem ritus unser kunde
ist im grundbuch als eine wenn man so
will sehr früh sehr frühe form von
kultur der vorteil auch von mir wir
weiter entwicklen bonitz kühl haben sich
sehr gut für die barolo damit der abend
mit denen großer landschaften die
religiosität der op de bakker das ist
schon sehr hat das bürgerliche und der
katholizismus spielt das neue runde
für sie also ich verbinde ich verbinde
religion jetzt nicht mit dem beratung
glauben sie ich glaube aber sehr wohl
dass es dass man wenn man in eine große
landschaft lebt und in der landschaft
spielt man die osze stärker man hat mich
als mensch als mensch an das
dimensioniert in dem ganzen team
ich glaube schon dass troge noch noch
herkunft frage wo er denn am schluss der
sind als in der umwelt wo zu 100 prozent
gemacht instrumente
[Musik]
ich lass dir gruppe vita probe
schließlich steht york premiere kurz
bevor bezaubert über nacht die in einer
hus wo nummer für essbar buche als hotel
i gerichtet ich will es aber neuen teil
vom politischen projekt eigentlich
schaut nur so gut sie zieht erscheint
mir als oberhaupt steine fielen dass ich
wie häufig berg ohne schnee undankbar
[Musik]
der bekannte stadt im tal ist aber nun
mit der drüber rock rebellen eine bevor
ich ganz der maria gewidmet und heißt
wie du mir so schlosser dollar dort
richten
giovanni netzer maria ich liebe meine
herkunft und zwar eine vor der komplette
staff molter maria kirche aus in der
schweiz gibt mit dem anspruch dass sie
die gesamte heilsgeschichte zu vom
sündenfall bis himmelfahrt mariens
abdeckt und damit man das er könne mache
hat man muss einer bar apokryphe quelle
bemühe das heißt für kindheit von
premier szene so zeigen findet in der
bibel stand respektiv apokryphen
evangelien ableiter das heißt er fahre
die der spd-politiker biblisch dort
genau mein fehler die umfassende
lebensgeschichte oder maria darsteller
mainwelle wisse wie sie aufgewachsen ist
was er als kind gemacht hat mein vater
zum beispiel dass sie in ihre kindheit
im tempel verbracht hat dass sie das
gelöbnis auf ihre jungfräulichkeit
abgehetzt all das ist dort in der
apokryphe von jacobus evangelium also
wir sind ja keine bilder durch so zeuge
vor dem leiter von der maria wir sind da
raus und ein bollwerk reformation oder
es sich also entweder in denen in denen
jahre tobt in graubünden eigentlich
reformation und gegenreformation mal
versucht die rtl haltermann hat
einerseits natürlich die konfessionelle
frage wo das thema sehen was geht im
hintergrund wie man es für politik also
mann der schnell vergessen und sind
besser
als große alpentransversalen auch
wichtig für die riech und oma wohin welt
erschaffen oder sich gegeneinander
abschotten und da kommt man in der
information der herr aus italien mit mit
der neustadt trend soll so man holt man
holt die neueste kirche baukunst mal die
besten moderatoren zu abonnieren
man baut architektonisch aktuell also
manchmal stellt die katholische
reformation als kultureller
trendsetterin der ruhm diese geprägt
sind und plötzlich der drei riesige
kirche mit einer schau fassade und dem
überschwang in der dekoration
sie zeige mir die kehle welt sieht
praktisch aufgewachsen sind sie ein tor
ministrieren was bedeutet denn di maria
in erhöht ich glaube dem rist chance
einer glaube zum zum als frau wäre der
wohl meine sehr spezifischen umfeld in
dem sie aufwachsen als als als mensch
das bestand hat das glaube ich
erkenntnis und auch errungenschaft oder
neuere technologie interessiert wo man
da in der kirche drin sind ist maria
team als königin steht ein
beschwerlicher weg dass sie sie
überstrahlt eigentlich alle irdischen
monarch hier und ist der zufluchtsort
schlechthin wenn man sich der himmel als
einen strengen ort vorstellen und jeden
kunden braucht der zuspruch von
mütterlicher figur wie man sie in
therapie zerstört
himmel und hölle legt man mal nach
bienen und
[Musik]
nunmehr grad 20 km von ihnen entfernt
hund marmorera und zum staudammbau
anfang der 50er jahre baut waren ich
damit sitzt serie nicht nur strom könnte
doch an die nummer mit dem lied kann
trainer abgemacht ist aber groß ja das
ist natürlich da leben xi und marmorera
ist strasser und gehen natürlich auch
verdient denn der julia roberts ist ja
ein richtig geregelt was da ist der
gleiche prozess gemacht mit dem da lobe
ich aber das hat natürlich das oberhaupt
stein wenn man so weit verändert ganz
klar mag es ja das stimmt mich jedes mal
traurig wenn die darüber am lauf warum
warum heute natürlich ist auch manager
gang und das ist auch eine kultur gang
was können wir hüten jeder machen meint
nicht nur dieser publikation
kulturbeutel tradition wo ich denn das
dorf silber starfish etwa ungefähr dort
wo der kran stand unterhalb von der
heutige julian rüter wieder eben diese
im archiv im film kunde über das alte
dorf marmorera aus der anzeige
das ist so spannend
das sieht man ja parat sie das ist
geldes muss land weil das großes dorf es
ist noch ein stattliches dorf gesehen
pressebox selbstgesprächen wäre der
häuser das kann die verschneite hallo
das ist das tut marie widor zu mensch
und kultur
zerstampft das würde heute nicht mehr
machen oder unmöglichkeit thema
natürlich an demokratischen prozessen
zum glück aber was ist denn da verloren
wenn sie sagt kultur die formulare
eintragen spruch kann ein ereignis
romanisch und ich glaube es gibt wenige
wo das nach und in marmorera die
schalter erwähnt die kapuziner pater
alexander lotz aufgewachsen sie seltener
hus ist verschwunden
aber die nacht kann trainer weiß
gestanden ich ungefähr da man muss sich
durch dieses holz höchsten vorstellen
40 sind und bei geisa vor allem malteser
sind kühe für den arc sie auf ihr
zerrinnt einer familie wie wird jetzt
gatte alexander lotz brier strom neuer
partner ja gut also ein so großer
familie ist das natürlich eine ehre sie
dass mindestens ein mal ein fahrer wird
und wie der taufe ein schock sei täglich
dort constantin alexander entweder
stirbt muss weg in der nächsten minute
so harten geredet oder er wird falsch
und das muss man sich vorstellen mit 14
hat man mich für genua backte website
am montag hat opera genua und in der
abgeschiedenheit oder lebten im kloster
und und heide überfällt ihn natürlich
einmal sogar dass ich lieber ort richtig
also von mir in der zelle das lächeln
das muss man sich vorstellen so hwk und
ich glaube das klingt dann auch wieder
gedicht also das high weg und immer
wieder wieder vor spannend herzlicher
dank twitter auf bios verhindern dass
sie mal kurz
ja da in bio teils das tal dahinter gott
zum julierpass dass sich ganze
klassische alpenübergang wenn man
richtig suter ist nadine will und der
hintere kurz über der seb thema pass was
ist möglich der alte pilger und handelns
war der krater und kaiser banken
die eine pilgertour maria ob sie teil
andere schöpfe das alte religiöse
traditionen und mache du bist groß wie
der andere und usaid natur oder den
pferdesattel ihn alle gemeinsam berge
sind ein sehnsuchtsort und der quelle
für ideen und spirituelle erfahrung
ich kann es nachvollziehen ja ich fühle
mich einfach wohl der berge in der natur
ihre ruhe
in der nächsten folge immer unterwegs im
puschlav ich freue mich bis bald
[Musik]